did you want to understand is the
connection between you know the
rectangular coordinates which are like a
left/right up/down kind of like an
etch-a-sketch sort of way of locating a
point and the polar way of locating a
point which is this circular way of
locating a point you've got the radius
and then you've got the angle to get to
this particular point so you can see
from this diagram that XY and R are
connected together by this equation x
squared plus y squared equals R squared
and that's just the Pythagorean theorem
you're familiar with that already
you can take the square root of both
sides and you can write R equals the
square root of x squared plus y squared
we're going to be using all of these
connections to translate the rectangular
equations into polar form so another
connection here you want to recognize is
that the tangent of theta equals y over
X okay so tangent of theta equals y over
X and if you take the tangent inverse of
both sides you get theta equals tangent
inverse of Y over X also the cosine of
theta is adjacent over hypotenuse so
let's just write that here so cosine
theta equals x over R and if you
multiply both sides by R you can see
that ax is going to equal R cosine theta
sine of theta is opposite over
hypotenuse so sine of theta equals y
over R if we multiply both sides by R
you can see that Y is equal to R sine
theta so we're going to be using all
these connections here to translate from
rectangular to polar so example number
one we've got x squared plus y squared
equals 9 if we go to this equation here
you can see X 4 plus y squared equals R
squared so let's go ahead and replace x
squared plus y squared with R squared
okay you can see our squared equals 9
and if we take the square root of both
sides we get R equals 3 now it should
make sense to you that you know when
you're in polar form when you're looking
at a circle with radius 3 that's this
outer one here that I've just drawn but
this is also the equation of a circle
it's just that it's in rectangular form
remember x squared plus y squared equals
the radius squared okay but this is a
simpler way of writing it when you use
polar coordinates so our goal is to get
rid of the X's
wize get everything in terms of ours and
Thetas okay so let's look at example
number two so here we have y equals five
and from our equations over here you can
see that Y is equal to R times a sine of
theta so let's go ahead and do that
replacement our sine theta equals five
and you know how when you normally write
equations of lines you say y equals
blank crap on polar form if possible you
try to get that our value by itself so
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to divide
both sides by sine of theta to get R by
itself and we have R equals five divided
by the sine of theta but we know that
the reciprocal of sine is cosecant so
this is really going to be five cosecant
theta and this is just another way of
representing the horizontal line y
equals five but in terms of the radius
and the angle okay so that's the polar
form okay example number three we've got
y equals x and so here what you want to
do is you want to either do the
replacement x equals our cosine in y
equals R sine theta let's go ahead and
do that so our sine theta equals R
cosine theta and then you can see if you
divide both sides by r those cancel out
and then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to divide both sides by cosine
theta okay both sides by cosine theta so
sine over cosine equals tangent of theta
okay and cosine divided by cosine is one
but you can see over here that we've got
theta equals tangent inverse of Y over X
so let's go ahead and take the tan
inverse of both sides tan inverse okay
have the left side tangent inverse of
the right side but what's the tangent
inverse of 1 well that's PI over 4 okay
and so here the tan inverse and the tan
those undo one another so we get theta
equals PI over 4 now in this case we
weren't able to get this in terms of
like R in terms of something we just
have the angle theta equals PI over 4
and if you know from plotting some of
these points on your polar graph paper
that you've been working with that the
angles PI over 4 so no matter what the
radius is if the radius is one day
angles PI over 4 if the radius is 2 the
angles still PI over 4 that radius is 3
it's PI over 4 so you can see what we're
getting here is this
why not a 45-degree angle which is the
same as the line y equals x in
rectangular form so these are just two
different ways of writing the equation
for that same line okay our last example
example number 4 x equals 2 same idea
we're going to replace X with what x
equals R cosine theta okay and then what
we want to do is you want to get that R
by itself so we're going to divide both
sides by cosine of theta so we get R
equals 2 over cosine theta and what's
the reciprocal of cosine of theta
well that's secant of theta so we've got
our equals 2 secant theta and you've got
it so this was just kind of a quick
whirlwind tour of how to do some of the
translations or transformations from
rectangular form to polar form so I hope
you enjoyed the video subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon